ce soir je vais vous raconter une
histoire l'histoire fantastique de notre
petite école en birmanie tout a commencé
et repose sur un adage un adage qui dit
tout simplement que si tu donnes un
poisson à quelqu'un qui a faim il aura à
manger un jour par contre si tu apprends
à pêcher à quelqu'un qui a faim alors tu
vas le nourrir et il aura à manger pour
toujours pour toute sa vie et pour nous
cet adage l'âme il a été hyper important
car apprendre offre quelque chose de
fondamental il offre de la joie il
procure des sensations agréables à
quelqu'un qui transmet son savoir à
quelqu'un d'autre mais il offre
j'allais dire surtout la liberté et
l'indépendance à celui qui reçoit
ce savoir par contre il ya une chose qui
est importante et vous vais j'y
reviendrai un peu plus tard c'est
parfois par excès de générosité et
j'allais dire on a tendance à oublier
que nos valeurs notre façon de vivre
n'est pas forcément celle des autres
regardez cette image
j'ai pris cette photo en février 2018
tout simplement à queue avec mon iphone
c'est dans notre école en birmanie moi
ce genre d'image elle m'a toujours
surpris on voit des jeunes qui sont
souriants un sourire qui est sincère
un sourire qui fait du bien il respire
le bonheur alors que ces cinq six gamins
que vous voyez sur cette image il ne
possède
absolument rien aucun biens matériels
ils vivent pieds nus jouent dans la
poussière
mais s'ils ne sont pas riches s'ils sont
pauvres même ne sont pas misérable pour
autant et là il ya une distinction qui
est très importante
la misère et la pauvreté la misère
pour nous c'est un synonyme de honte la
honte de ne pas être intégrée au sein de
la société ne pas être intégrée au sein
d'une communauté
alors que la pauvreté elle s'est bien
souvent quelques chiffres sur un compte
en banque
et paradoxalement en voyageant dans les
pays d'asie du sud-est dans les pays
pauvres d'afrique subsaharienne bain
paradoxalement j'avais souvent des
images de notre valet il y avait
quelques décennies il a 50 60 ans et
plus
ce wallemme notre vallée nos villages où
les gens les populations vivait
modestement je pourrais presque dire les
populations elles vivaient de façon
pauvres mais par contre je relèverai qui
on y trouvait une forme de solidarité
qu'on a peut-être tendance un peu oublié
aujourd'hui et je revoyais ces images
pardon pour la qualité elle est un petit
peu ancienne de ces grandes salles de
classe avec une cinquantaine d'étudiants
alignés les uns à côté des autres sur
des bancs en bois à se partager un même
plumier avec pour seul et unique confort
si on peut appeler ça un confort un poil
pour les réchauffer et je revoyais aussi
dans ma tête
cette image du curé ce curé qui avaient
ce rôle de médiateur familial
le curé c'est aussi évidemment le guide
spirituel
le curé il jouait le rôle de juge de
policiers mais c'était surtout le régent
celui qui transmettait les fondamentaux
celui qui transmettait le savoir
l'éducation
mais revenons à nos petits birman
revenons en birmanie au sud reliant
guînes tout a commencé
c'était quoi vers noël 2007 j'étais sur
les bancs de l'université en asie et je
côtoyais la des amis asiatiques dont une
birmane avec qui j'aime et bien à
discuter et un jour je la questionner
sur l'après tsunami qui avait ravagé son
pays en 2004
trois ans auparavant je demandais tout
simplement comment elle s'est organisée
pour reconstruire le pays
et évidemment comment ils avaient
utilisé les fonds donnés par les
organisations internationales par les
pays occidentaux et larmes avec ce grand
sourire qui caractérise les populations
d'asie du sud-est avec un brin de
philosophie je dois dire aussi
elle me disait que elle elle préférait
regarder la paix vers l'avenir plutôt
que comme nous souvent en occident vers
le passé avec nostalgie voire même
presque souvent tristesse
à se poser des questions pour des
réponses finalement impossible
des réponses toutes façons qui resteront
dans le passé mais elle m'a avoué une
chose quand même assez dramatique que
l'ensemble des fonds qui avaient été
récoltés avaient été confisqués par la
junte militaire au pouvoir
ces militaires qui contrôlait le pays de
façon dictatoriale depuis plus de 42 ans
est là quand on vous dit ça quand vous
dites mince à quoi bon donner de
l'argent est généreux faire un don dans
une organisation x ou y
si au final c'est pour tomber dans les
mains de dictateurs de gens malveillants
bien de nouveau avec son petit sourire
me taper sur l'épaule et me dit tu sais
alex si dans notre histoire si notre
pays avait attendu sur la générosité sur
l'argent des pays occidentaux
ça ferait longtemps qu on serait tous
morts morts de désespoir et c'est pas un
petit bout d'os et merci donc mort de
désespoir mais la vie dans son pays
bâle a continué elle a continué
normalement et puis là bas c'est là que
tu dis finalement elle te rappelle aussi
que ces valeurs ce que je vous ai dit
avant leur façon de vivre leur réalité
ce n'est pas la même que chez nous et
elle m'a aussi dit qu'avec des petits
moyens financiers dans son pays
on pouvait faire de grandes choses et là
boum
le pulse de ces images du valais ils se
reconstituent dans ma tête et je me suis
dit lundi qu on va faire un projet
complètement fou et ce projet ça a été
de faire une école une école pour donner
un accès à l'éducation à des jeunes à
des enfants qui n'auraient jamais les
moyens
puis l'homme comme j'aime les images de
ce ballet d'il ya quelques années
derrière un demi-siècle et puces j'ai
commencé à approcher les temples
monastique de la région du sud de yangon
la banlieue les bidonvilles de yang
yunhe dans les tops monastique
j'ai trouvé les moines les moines c'est
quoi ces nos curés birman ce qui
dispensait du savoir ce qui allait
pouvoir transmettre leurs connaissances
dans les tops monastique
j'allais trouver quoi une infrastructure
des salles de classe 1 si j'allais
pouvoir contourner toute forme de
corruption et troisième chose dans les
tops monastique
on allait pouvoir profiter de la
tradition bouddhiste qui est sur
l'offrande
ainsi on avait notre cantine scolaire
donc en dépensant pratiquement rien on
avait déjà une structure capable
d'accueillir des enfants en organisant
les choses en permettant de valoriser
des compétences des gens notre école
vous pouvez démarrer mais notre souci
assez vite a été un souci de pérennité
si on fait un projet le but c'est qu'ils
perdurent dans le temps et là nous on a
eu donc de réflexion la première ils
doivent être indépendants libre de tout
engagement de nous de l'occident aussi
on s'est dit qu'on n'allait pas
s'immiscer dans leur éducation
n'oubliez pas notre réalité n'est pas la
leur ils font à leur manière même si
c'est un petit peu bricolé pour nous
même si c'est différent
par contre on avait à coeur de leur
offrir une valeur ajoutée
il faut savoir que la birmanie c'est un
pays qui tend à s'ouvrir au tourisme
donc on sait dire un petit peu
logiquement que l'anglais allait
permettre à ces jeunes enfants
défavorisés d'avoir un avantage
compétitif face aux autres et pouvoir
profiter s'émanciper par la suite
aussi plutôt que dire à des professeurs
anglophones occidentale d'aller étudier
ou des étudiants universitaires et c'est
de faire un séjour humanitaire là bas et
donc de provoquer une dépendance
vis-à-vis de nous on a choisi de donner
des cours d'anglais au moins
d'instructeurs ainsi qu'aux professeurs
de l'école 1,6 allez pouvoir transmettre
leur savoir deuxième aspect dans la
pérennité
c'était l'aspect monétaire qu'est ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on donne
directement dans les mains de ces gens
de l'argent est-ce qu'on paye
directement des infrastructures mais là
aussi toujours le même problème
le jour où tu arrêtes de payer plus rien
ne fonctionne rappelez-vous l'adage si
tu donnes un poisson à quelqu'un qui a
faim il aura mangé un jour si tu donnes
de l'argent à une organisation
elle va vivre pendant 3 6 mois 12 mois
par contre si tu apprends à pêcher c'est
la liberté aussi
on a eu l'idée d'acheter des rizières en
achetant des rizières
le deal qu'on a fait avec les paysans de
la région c'était qu'un tiers de la
rizière irait à cet agriculteur
ainsi ils allaient pu subvenir aux
besoins de sa propre famille et avec les
deux tiers restants le surplus le
bénéfices dégagés permettraient de
financer nos activités dans le temple on
faisait fonctionner ainsi leur propre
circuit économique
troisième aspect ici sur la photo les
ventes de gâteaux transmettre nos
valeurs je transmette plutôt ses valeurs
à nos jeunes nos jeunes de l'école à
sion et là on a une idée toute simple
organisé une fois par mois par une
classe différente
une vente de gâteaux cette vente de
gâteaux les jeunes comme vous le voyez
sur cette image la veille doivent
s'organiser ensemble avec leurs parents
leurs grands parents etc pour faire une
tarte pour faire des biscuits etc
chaque récréation lors de ces ventes de
gâteaux on arrive le vin à fond d'à peu
près 300 francs en termes de valeur vous
allez me dire que 300 francs c'est pas
grand chose mais quand on explique à ces
jeunes que 300 francs cela représente 5
% du budget annuel de l'école que cela
permet d'offrir du savoir et la liberté
à 8 10 enfants de notre école
vous voyez que le message est bien
différent et le but il est là c'est de
créer un lien un lien même virtuel à
distance malien sincère entre nos
enfants et ses enfants enfin demain dans
le futur soyons fous et rêvons et d'où
notre rêve c'est que finalement nos
petits birman mais ils puissent
eux-mêmes transmettre leur savoir le
savoir qu'elles ont acquis dans l'âtre
écoles aux autres gamins de leur village
pour leur offrir un avenir meilleur et
ainsi ils deviendront eux-mêmes ce
qu'ils apprennent à pêcher un poisson
non ce ne sera pas aux apprenants
[Musique]
nosocomiales aux tornades
oui j'ai un bep en installant dossier
elle
[Musique]
owni le new labour connais la ville de
dhamir
autant daryl hannah de tabac dans
l'yonne la guitare
[Musique]
on est bien
une note
[Musique]
oh
c'est la tonalité
j'essaye d'aller au charbon
hautmont
dornach a permis d'avancer vers le
tournoi de soccer à nous
on
quand ma mère
enfin les eaux
[Musique]
moyen terme
il a servi
[Musique]
on est alors donnée
attendons bien
juste en face de mentionner de noms des
communes et l'anti nucléaire
[Musique]
permanent les cinq internationaux
toulouse avoir été ruiné la pièce des
génomes
[Musique]
smara on est bien il a écrit alain
goulet pillage systématique pourrait
devenir lé métro fini à petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]